these next clips are an absolute
pleasure to watch uh donald trump's
kooky lawyer rudy giuliani has turned on
donald trump's kooky lawyer sydney
powell
now there are about four or five layers
of hilarity here the first layer of
hilarity is that weeks ago
when sydney powell appeared to go crazy
at these events at which she appeared
with rudy giuliani claiming hugo chavez
and venezuela cuba and tifa
were all involved in stealing the
election oh george soros too
trump put out a statement saying this
woman has no involvement with this
period she's
working by herself then rudy giuliani
went
justice bonkers himself telling us about
as crazy of a story about what happened
with the election then trump had sidney
powell
at the oval office on friday and she was
the one pushing trump to do absolutely
ridiculous things like
trying to forcibly seize voting machines
and then the latest just incredible uh
uh event in this series of of
embarrassment
is that rudy giuliani appeared yesterday
on sean spicer's news max program
and appeared to turn on sydney powell
now before we even get to that
sean spicer's newsmax program yes
sean spicer donald trump's former white
house press secretary
has a show on newsmax that alone is
hilarious but i can't even focus on that
because we have to get to what rudy says
here is rudy insinuating that sydney
powell's approach
is outside of rationality common sense
and
the law take a look right and i know
some of these folks have picked her up
going in and out of the
the west wing but is she the best of
your knowledge meeting with the
president
about some of these strategic moves to
either
impound or seize voting machines or
become a special counsel to investigate
fraud
well look it's my responsibility as the
president's lawyer along with jenna
and some of the others we're going to be
extremely aggressive we're going to
fight for our client as hard as we can
but we're also going to do it within the
bounds of rationality common sense
and the law and it can be done
there's no reason to go beyond anything
that there was this election was a theft
it can be proven i can tell you one
simple thing that would prove it
make the american people feel really
good five or six of these
crooked governors could let us have
access
to the machines what's really just
kafkaesque here
is that rudy giuliani is no voice of
reason rudy giuliani is pursuing ideas
that are almost as nutty as what he's
saying
sidney powell is going too far with but
he says
she's going too far and she's not
working with us well rudy you're doing
things that are essentially as bonkers
as what she's doing
uh here is rudy in plain english saying
sydney powell is on her
own rudy by the way appears to be doing
the interview from a restaurant it
sounds like there's silverware clanking
in the background
but i want to bring you back to these
reports that in the oval office
sydney powell who had been part of your
legal team until she was dismissed
has been there at least three
potentially four times so
there's a rumor that she is trying to
become or
people are advocating that she'd be
appointed special counsel and that their
voting machines be seen can you tell us
what's happening in the oval office and
what her role will be
let me say definitively cindy powell is
not part of our legal team
she hasn't been for five weeks she is
not a special counsel for the president
she does not speak for the president nor
does she speak for the administration
she speaks for herself and she's a fine
woman a fine lawyer
but whatever she is talking about it's
her own opinions i'm not responsible for
them the president isn't
nor is anybody else on our legal team so
now rudy is both distancing himself from
sydney powell but at the same time
not and what i mean by that is he says
she's not part of the legal team
well we knew that we knew trump trump
claimed that weeks ago
rudy says she's not special counsel well
we know that right now she's not special
counsel the story is trump is
thinking about making her special
counsel rudy says she doesn't speak for
the president
no one claimed she did she's not his
press secretary and
rudy says she doesn't speak for the
trump administration again nobody has
claimed that so
notice how rudy distances while not
actually refuting the assertions which
include sydney powell was at the oval
office on friday
sydney powell met with trump sydney
powell suggested a seizure of voting
machines and trump is thinking about
appointing her special counsel rudy
doesn't debunk any of that
he just generally distances and then
lastly and this is so funny
here's rudy on newsmax with sean spicer
now attacking fox news saying fox news
won't let him on anymore to make his
voter fraud claims
i can't get on i can't get on abc nbc
cbs can't even get a fox anymore
if i say the word fraud i'm thrown off
the network
i'm sorry there was fraud
i'm telling the truth and they're lying
completely
indistinguishable from parody at this
point
very strange times that we we live in
i'm shocked daily
that this is real life and speaking of
fox news
let's talk about what happened there i
want to take a second to tell you about
one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol
wipes no touch infrared thermometers and
all of their prices
are very reasonable i also love snh
masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over 150 dollars you
can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david